do you like borat
you know what i like stack with me
though the first one i like
me too after that i felt like it was
just making fun of people and then
hiding behind lawyers
there you go yeah which is the most
ratchet [ __ ] i think you can
look bro real talk oh i'm so happy
because what he does is he just goes to
like where you're from and goes look how
stupid these people are yeah yeah that's
like his whole stick
yeah go do it in your hometown go do it
in your [ __ ] hometown where you came
from [ __ ] whatever you got dude
and then he goes yeah but here's the
thing what annoys me the most about him
is that
i'm fine if that's your prank show let's
say you just have a prank show and
that's what
he does on showtime yeah but that's fine
and it's just a prank show but then he
got up in one of these [ __ ] award
shows and goes
i'm exposing racism yes anti-semitism
he went too far left he went too far he
just got on a pedestal and it's like
dude you're
you have the lowest brow humor yeah okay
and you're just
making fun of people that were kind to
you yeah literally people like would you
like to come in my
taking him over and then he just [ __ ]
him over it makes him look real stupid
i didn't know it was like that yeah
people don't know
he goes he goes to louisiana he goes and
he goes can i come into your house with
a stupid accent the people go i don't
even know who you are
christian i feel like he's anti-white i
don't know i don't know what his deal is
bro but
yeah some of this shit's on everybody
it's just mean
thanks thanks man and i hate i just
get off your [ __ ] high horse i
stopped watching off the first one
first one i was alright i'm all right
but ali g was good man
was unbelievable but he was different
then dude i love the movies
it was i and i'm fine with you having
the prank show if you just come out and
go yeah i'm a piece of [ __ ] i prank
people that's fine like i'm totally fine
with that great awesome he's trying to
act like he's a good person
he's acting like he's saving the world
no he's not acting like he's
bringing light to bro you know yeah
there's a [ __ ] charity called uh
uh stop hate for profit your whole show
is hate for profit that's what you do
[Music]
yeah yeah true i just know that you like
and how big it is to go to a place and
then be mean to people
you know what i'm saying yeah but how
nice are these people horrible how nice
are these people to let them into their
homes and their businesses
you're taking it lights them on fire
it's unbelievable and then he asks them
that inflammatory basically
go in their bathroom he shits in a bag
and he runs out of their house yelling
you hate black people
all he does what are we even talking
about and the guy thinks he's some
[ __ ] genius
he stinks
[Music]
is